KRISH SIVAKUMAR: Hi, and
welcome to our session
on Google Compute Engine.
Today, we'll provide you with
an overview of the portfolio
and walk through the
roadmap of what's coming
with Google Compute Engine.
My name is Krish Sivakumar.
I'm part of the product
management team in the Google
Cloud organization.
Let's start with looking
at Google Cloud Vision.
As you're digitally
transforming your enterprises,
Google Cloud is providing
you organizations the best
infrastructure and platform
capabilities coupled
with industry-leading
solutions portfolio
to enable such a
transformation to happen.
As we look at Google Cloud, the
Compute Engine is at its core.
Within the Compute Engine,
there are a variety
of things that are available
from an overall portfolio
perspective for
your infrastructure.
And your infrastructure matters.
And the reason the
infrastructure matters
is all of the right
business decisions
get powered through
your infrastructure,
and the portfolio breadth
of the infrastructure
essentially enables a wide
variety of applications
to become available.
And the infrastructure
continues to be moving forward
to accommodate changes to your
applications and workloads.
We also want to
make sure that we're
providing your teams
the kind of platform
that they would need,
be it the scientists
or the data analysts or
engineers or developers.
Google Cloud and Compute Engine
provide the broadest variety
of capabilities that
cater to the needs of all.
Diving a little
deeper, we're going
to start looking at the
performance and flexibility
capabilities of Google Cloud
for your enterprise workloads.
To lead that, I want to
welcome Aaron Blasius.
AARON BLASIUS: Thank you, Krish.
At Compute Engine, we
understand that enterprises
have a diverse and
evolving set of workloads
and that different workloads
come with different priorities.
You may have mission
critical databases,
where every drive in
performance counts.
Or you may have back
office applications,
for which total cost
of ownership is king.
Google Cloud provides you with
a flexible range of capabilities
to match whatever demands
your workloads may have,
and we deliver them
around the world.
We have data centers
on six continents.
And all of our regions come
with three availability zones
as standard, delivering
your workloads
to your users and your
customers wherever they may be.
We provide the compute power
of Google Compute Engine
through our VM family portfolio.
We have the right capabilities
for your workloads
across the spectrum
of offerings.
We have compute optimized, E2.
We have general
purpose, which is
backed by both Intel and AMD.
We have compute
optimized for your HPC
and your scientific
modeling applications.
We can also go up to the high
end for your SAP HANA databases
or your largest in-memory
databases with our memory
optimized family.
And we are proud to
announce that coming soon,
we will be adding
a new VM family, A2
which has the highest
performance GPUs in the market.
And of course, your
compute is only
as good as the
storage behind it.
We we're expecting and we're
expanding our persistent disk
offering to provide you with
the same flexibilities as our VM
families.
Some workloads, we're
optimized for TCO,
where we will have an
efficient PD offering,
as well as going
into performance
and extreme for your most
mission critical applications.
And of course,
local SSD continues
to expand with 9
terabyte offerings.
You can move data around with
Google's world class cloud
network.
We offer a variety of
options for our customers,
include with low latency,
large block sizes, and IPv6
and as well as
bring your own IP--
important capabilities
for any enterprise.
Now of course, for those really,
really specialized workloads,
we now have Baremetal solutions.
Baremetal solutions is an Intel
Cascade Lake back offering
with a variety of
sizes and storage
options for your special needs.
These are set for
applications that
may need to have access to
either the special processor
options that are not offering
through virtualization
or things that require Baremetal
for licensing or locale.
And of course, our
ML infrastructure,
where we are expanding to A2,
or accelerator-optimized family,
with A100 NVIDIA GPUs, 100
gig networking, and of course,
our TPU offerings.
What's new with TPUs?
Well, TPUs, we are going with
TPU version 2 and version 3
Pods are now available
in GA, delivering up
to 420 teraflops of
floating point performance,
and include custom
high speed network
that Allows TPUs
to work together.
We are also expanding
our software ecosystem
to help customers build the
highest performing support
and model libraries
in the market today.
TPUs are also generally
available and backed with GKE,
and is a great way to run your
containerized enterprise email.
Google Cloud also continues
to expand its partnership
with NVIDIA.
A100 NVIDIA and pure GPU is now
available in the A2 VM family
with optimized accelerators
for AI, ML, and HPC.
K80 started the AML training
workload two years ago,
and we are now expanding
those capabilities.
P100, V100 top of the line
GPUs for high end training
or joining our portfolio,
as well as P4 and T4
inference for hyperscale.
We were the first cloud to
launch that and the only one
to offer it globally.
T4 has the same tensor
core as the V100
and is a great option for
scale out training if the V100
compute is beyond your needs.
Now
Now all of this--
delivering these innovative
enterprise solutions
requires a full stack.
And that's where I would
like to turn it over to Krish
now to discuss.
KRISH SIVAKUMAR: Thanks, Aaron.
Aaron just discussed the
incredible performance
and flexibility that
Google Cloud offers.
Let's talk about the things
that you could actually
do on top of that
performance and flexibility
that Google Cloud offers.
So let's take a look at some
of the enterprise solutions.
The first one we'll talk about
is the Google VMware engine.
GVE, as we fondly call
it, is an incarnation
of your trusted VMware
portfolio, including
vSphere, vSAN, and NSX, combined
into an asset service offering
that you could simply
consume off of Google Cloud.
There are a number
of innovative things
that are happening
as part of GVE.
And if you look at that roadmap,
starting from the debut of GVE
shortly, there is a
significant amount of expansion
that is happening at Google
speed to new regions.
And then offerings
that are coupled
with the GVE offering that
span the broad portfolio of GCP
or Google Cloud.
Available at launch is a
comprehensive set of vCenter
and NSX manager capabilities.
Right from day zero,
more than any other cloud
provider, seamlessly integrated
with the GCP experience--
a single place for billing,
identity and access management,
and VPC-level protection.
Let's take another solution.
SAP on GCP.
We're offering a
wide spread of sizes
to meet a variety
of customer demands
from the smallest
128 gig offering
to the largest 24
terabyte plus offering
for SAP HANA workloads.
And then providing more
choices, including the AMD,
we call the N2D platform, that
are 30% faster and cheaper
than previous offerings.
Continuing to provide the
certification associated
with SAP HANA is an integral
part of this overall offering.
Let's take a look at some
additional enterprise solutions
that are there.
The next one we're going to
take a look at is Windows.
As you can imagine, the
large variety of workloads
today continue to run
on Windows and GCP
provides a first class
Windows experience
for all of our customers.
And this first class experience
includes a Managed Active
Directory capability.
It includes MS SQL
as part of cloud SQL.
And support for
Windows containers
as part of the GKE offering,
all available today.
Coming soon as
part of our roadmap
is the ability to migrate
with Anthos for Windows
and automatically re-platform
your existing Windows Server
2008 R2 into Windows 2012 as
part of the migration itself.
And then there are further
enhancements both to GKE
and to the Windows
managed ED offering
that we are planning on.
Looking at the next step from
an overall solution standpoint,
there are times that you want
to have a level of isolation
for your workloads and the
no share type of methodology.
Google Cloud offers that
level of control and isolation
and separation through
its sole tenancy offering.
A sole tenancy offering
allows you to run
GCD VMs on dedicated hardware.
And they are best for cases
where you have a compliance
need that is rooted on things
like licensing, PCI compliance,
Capex accounting, and such.
Over the next two
quarters, as we
continue to evolve the
sole tenancy offering,
we aim to ensure that you would
have support for the entire VM
portfolio as we have it,
including local SSDs and GPUs.
Now as we look at all of
these solutions, a lot of this
depends on the migration
of your workloads
from the existing
on prem environment
onto the GCE environment.
To do that, we have
a variety of steps
that are curated that
both GCE and our partners,
Google's partners, can
collectively offer for you.
This includes the
discovery and assessment.
The planning that's
required for organizing your
on prem workloads and
bringing them onto TCP.
The act of migration itself.
And the post-migration
activities
that you'll need to do to ensure
that the migrated environment
is fully optimized from a
cost, performance, and security
standpoint inside of GCP.
If you were to double click a
little bit on the Migrate step,
we have a number
of new enhancements
that are available.
Specifically, as you're looking
at migrating your Windows 2008
R2 environment, like
we spoke before,
replatforming allows
you to turn that
into a server 2012
environment as part
of the migration itself.
Cloud to cloud migration,
both from AWS and Azure,
into Google Cloud has
never been easier.
In addition to that, whether
you're bringing your own Linux
or you're in the
container world,
or you're bringing
Windows containers,
we made it very easy for you
to add them into Google Cloud.
Looking at that
a little further,
beyond the performance and
flexibility that Google Cloud
offers, and all of the
different enterprise solutions
if you can run on
top of Google Cloud,
we also aim to provide an
operational environment that
is the most conducive
in your cloud.
To do that, we start
with live migration.
Maintenance is an integral part
of running any infrastructure,
but not in all cases
does maintenance
need to be disrupted.
Actively managing your
infrastructure and application
available, we don't have to be
an either/or option, at all.
Google Cloud's innovative
live migration capabilities
ensure that your
workloads are not
impacted while the underlying
infrastructure goes
through maintenance.
A lot of times, we have a need
to manage multiples of VMs
together as a group.
And that's really what
managed instance groups allows
you to do.
This is a way in which
Google Cloud allows
you to take an instance, and
then create multiple the VMs
from that instance.
And the capability
for management
doesn't stop at
just the creation
of those multiple instances,
but from an ongoing management
standpoint, whether
it comes to patching,
whether it's come
to auto scaling,
or whether it comes to auto
healing after environment.
Managed instant
groups or MIGs allow
you to take the burden off of
group management of multiples
off VMs.
Continuing on the
operational excellence theme,
we are also proud to present
a number of recommendations
that are integral to your
Google Cloud experience.
These recommendations span
a broad variety of areas,
including cost, security,
efficiency, just to name a few.
The traditional approach to
managing your cloud environment
is to throw more money or staff
at the problem, in many cases,
infinitely expanding
your capacity
without fully
knowing whether that
is being adequately utilized.
Google's active assist
recommendations allow you
to right size your environment,
allow you to learn more
about idle resources,
and providing you
that automated proactive
intelligence that
gives you the ability
to do more with less.
As an example, Google
Cloud uses our intelligence
to automate the cooling
of our own data centers.
Top of the mind
for every customer
is the total amount of spend
that they have for their cloud.
Visibility, control,
and optimized cost
are very important.
Google Cloud offers coveted
use discounts or CUDs
that provide the best possible
pricing through deep discounts
against long term commitments.
Recently, we expanded our CUDs
to allow for multi project
coverage where you could go
ahead and then apply cuts
through multiple
parallel projects
that you have as part
of your organization.
In addition to that, we have
a number of new capabilities
that are coming up, including
auto-renewing your CUDs
as they come up on their
one year or three year
anniversaries, and also, the
ability to schedule the start
and stop of your VMs
in order to right size
them at any given
time to conserve
the total use of the
number, of course,
that you would have as
part of your commits.
It also does suspend
and resume VMs as part
of this overall offering.
Patch management is an
incredibly hard problem
to manage, and typically
presents a significant burden
as part of infrastructure
management.
Google Cloud lifts
that burden away
by leveraging native OS
tools and automating the task
of patch management for you.
We have wide coverage
of all popular operating
systems spanning from Windows
to several flavors of Linux.
Google Cloud also provides a
number of different controls
that allow you to target
specific hosts as part
of your overall infrastructure
within Google cloud.
And also provide
the ability for you
to schedule your
maintenance windows
and orchestrate
your patch actions
as part of an overall
patching capability.
Last but not least on
the operational end,
we're also providing OS config
management capabilities that
are today at beta.
Managing configuration
and configuration drifts
is a hard problem, and
we aim to make that easy.
With this new beta, an
OS config management,
we're presenting a
compliance dashboard
that gives you details on
config across Linux and Windows
and across hybrid clouds.
You can use third
party config tools
if you choose to bootstrap
packages and deploy
and maintain configurations
coupled with drift prevention
very easily.
With that in mind,
if we kind of look
at the stack a level higher,
and look at security and data
protection, they
are integral parts
of an overall cloud portfolio.
To further the
discussion on that,
I'd like to turn it
over back to Aaron.
AARON BLASIUS: Thank you, Krish.
As you said, security
and data protection
are key to in cloud offering.
As cloud adoption grows,
so too does the challenge
of keeping your cloud
workloads secure and protected.
Security and data protection
are Google's top priority,
and our infrastructure
is designed, built,
and operated with into and
security is a core design
principle.
From the physical premises
to the purpose built servers,
networking equipment, security
chips, low level software
stack running on every
machine, our entire hardware
infrastructure is
Google-controlled, secured,
built, and hardened.
And for many cases, the
security is transparent to you
as a customer.
But just by the virtue of
operating on Google GCP,
you are getting these benefits.
Today, we'll be presenting a
number of exciting new features
in that area that we can
extend as a result of our end
to end security practices.
The first is confidential VMs.
Customers can run any workload
that they usually run in a VM.
And by clicking a
simple checkbox,
it will transform their
VM into a confidential VM.
Now all the memory pages
of the confidential VM
are inline encrypted.
The VMMemory it is
encrypted by a key per VM
and generated in hardware.
This is an AMD
offering and we are
very excited to
partner with them
in bringing this to market.
And finally, the customers
can protect their data
and to end in transit and
at rest as well as in use.
Shielded VMs are
also in GA, and this
is something I thought it would
be important to highlight.
Shielded VMs are
virtual machines
on Google Cloud hardened by
a set of security controls
that can help defend against
root kits and boot kit attacks.
The set of capabilities
ensure that your VM instances
have a healthy and
verified operating system.
It also means that protection
from malicious systems,
firmware, and guest operating
systems, tampering, et cetera--
we harden it against
those attacks.
We do this through security
features up and down the stack,
including UEFI firmware, secure
boot, and virtual trusted
platform or TPM.
These integrity
measures make it so
that you can trust the
operating systems that
are running on cloud.
Additionally, we are
offering data protection.
Today, customers
have just one size
fits all option for data
management at a snapshot.
Our goal for 2020 is to make
sure that copy data management
that fits for workload goals.
If you don't want to
do backups, but you
do want to fork off your
production disk for testing,
staging, et cetera, then we
will clone the disks for you.
I'm sorry-- the clone
disk options are for you.
Useful for quickly
investigating production issues
or performing
backup verifications
without destroying
disturbing productions.
If you want to efficiently
share data with a partner,
then CBT is the
offering for you.
And if the workload
spans the machines,
then it's GMI,
Google Machine Image,
which is coming out of beta.
And finally, I'd like to wrap
up with our call to actions.
Please continue
to visit NEXT' 20
and look at our on air
updates from our executives.
We will also be diving deeper
into each of these areas--
storage, TPU and
GPU accelerators,
security through other sessions.
We invite you to discover why
the world's most innovative
companies are
choosing Google Cloud,
and we would love for you to
visit our YouTube channel,
where you can work with
builders to explore APIs, data
analytics, machine learning, and
the very best tools that Google
Cloud has to offer.
Once again, I'd like to
thank my co-presenter, Krish,
for his help today,
and the team that
worked with us to put this
presentation together for you.
Thank you very much for your
interest in Google Cloud.
Hope to see you out there soon.